腰围66
哪拉伸96
臀围
臀围110
肩膀35
裤肠91
来这个
这个9块钱
9块扣个1
在我们这里理科
早几年都是文科人选的比较多
这几年理科也是多了
我让我老二爷也选理科到时候
我妈文科选学校
就那几个学校
没啥好选的
那个
那个啥
那个专业也没有多少好的啥专业
还是理科比较多
来这个后面是有一个豆弄
这个后面有个小豆弄
9块钱
这个标的是一个棉67的
棉67的这个牌子
9块9块
不介意的扣1扣1
这个地方有个小豆弄
9块9块扣个1
9块扣个1扣个1
9块钱扣个1
来这一款
这个是咖色
咖色
咖色的这一条
嗯
这个属于一个七八分的一个裤
两边有鞋扎兜的
然后这个标了一个M码
G是87
人勉9
Gm是4
这个春牛
春牛天川
腰围68
68到94
腿围
腿围106120
当场35
后场是90
这个39扣5
现在数学还有加上对文科人不利
来这个
3939扣3扣3
39扣个3扣个3
反正反正现在还是比比较那个好一点
不知道
成绩好
选啥都好
成绩不好选啥都不好
啥都不好选头疼
选这个玩意也是也是头疼我跟你说
天天偷人
不好好学习你说怎么整
加成是在选科室加分的
哦
数学加分加的比较多吗
加分加的多
来这一个
这个牌这个牌子的
好像物理化学
你如果考零费的话也都有几十费加了
是不是这个意思
来这个
这个底下拼接一个学访
学访的
短袖
来这个胸围的话是96104
长度68
9块
扣8
9块9块
扣8扣8
9块扣个8
扣个8
主要是我们
文科他又不喜欢读又
不喜欢背的
自由上理科了
为积分的写
对呀
文科没有吗文科也得有加分的项目吧
来这个
这个是这个是一个大袖子的
这一款
大这个泛蓝色的一个短袖
丝滑的很这一款
胸围106 110
长度
长度62的
长度62
9块钱
9块9块
扣个2
扣2扣2这一款
藏蓝色藏蓝色的这一款
短袖
9块9块
扣个2扣个2
就圆扣2
香港有如日文
西班牙文
还有这样子的
我们这里私立学校有这个
有学如果你英文不好的话可以报其他的什么这个语那个语的
英语不好可以报其他的
这有额外加分
对
来这个
但不是很多人去读
我们这里也是有
也有读的读的人也不多
胸围102
102 110
长度58
9块9块
扣8扣8
9块9块扣个8扣个8
这个这个袖子的话是这样子的
袖子是一个蝴蝶结的这种
一个小袖子
7天多掉回家里的
学法呢
9块钱
扣8扣8
9块扣个8
仇人天天不好好学习在家天天抱着手机刷
学谁家的那个圈
来这个
这个是一个小吊带
后面刺绣的这一款
小吊带
来这个尺寸
胸围是72到92
72 92
来一长
一长54
9块钱
扣8扣8
9块扣个8
小吊带
袋子是
上面是有一个小那个这个套在脖子上的应该是
这个白色白色一个小吊带
刺绣一个粉色的刺绣
9块9块
扣
扣2扣2
9块钱扣个2
来这个Mosen
Mosen一个L号
Mosen Mosen一个L号
两边有电击
这边肩膀上撑起来是这样子的
公主肩一样很好看
这个是一个蓝色格子的
绿色格子的
胸围
胸围92 98
92 98
长度51
这个29扣个1
Mosen的Mosen
还有一个粉色格子
这是有两个颜色的这一款
来这个29块
扣1扣1
29扣个1
29块
扣1扣1
这个发型
这个全棉的一个大卫衣高货高货
这个原来卖79的现在39
出来一个这个
有腰的布有腰的布
孩子也拍一个
这个原来79的这个位也不能那个过
39块粉色粉色的1
来这一款
这个是
这个是一个织筒织筒这一条裤
两边有写啥口袋
这个版型也好看
看看大裤嘴米色的
来腰围
腰围是64
64到88
64 88
肯定为1122
当长37
裤长是88
来这个咱们有腰的39
扣1
39块
扣1扣1这一款
扣个1
39块
上衣是哪一个
..39..39..
这有一个裙
这个是个枫叶不是裙
我有些裙子呢
棉子布
特别薄这一款
来来来来来来这一款
这个是少扣子
然后腰上有腰带这个应该是棉和人棉混合的
有个大腰带
两边有纸纱口袋的这一款
来这个
胸围灰色的灰色
胸围是110的
这是114
110 114
这款长的一个枫叶
长度106的
长度106
这个缺扣子
有扣眼
sufficient
有有有隐形的扣眼
有扣眼 小扣子
贴一下
这样一个版型
棉和人棉混纺的一款风衣
这个有要的扣29扣5
29块扣5扣5
原价99的这个
两边有直插口袋
面料是一个棉和人棉混纺的
棉和人棉混纺的一个面料
袖子上有两个装饰扣
就是缺了几个扣子
扣眼有的
缺了几个扣子
回去你们装几个扣就可以了
腰带也不少
腰带也有
这个29扣2扣2
棉和人棉
原价99的一个高货
风衣啊
薄的很
特别薄
而且柔软的
来另一个
这个是一个小背心
这一款背心
一边窄的带子的
这样的一个斜肩的
来这个胸围
胸围是88的
拉伸112
长度长度55的长度55
来这个9块9块扣个5
9块钱9块钱扣5扣5
背肩
有缘扣5
来这条裤
这个裤子缺了扣子
有扣眼
少扣子的这个
少扣子有拉链
牛仔牛仔的一条弯刀裤
宝刀眼这一块
特薄
这个有锡标
M码
锡标还给包上了
棉62
锯纸36
圈纸2
来腰围
腰围是72
72到92的腰
臀围
臀围是110
裆长36
裤长102
这个有腰的扣
看裤型
这样子的
M码
弯刀裤
这个很薄
很薄
里面不加绒
就缺了个扣子
少了个扣子
少了个扣
89块弯刀裤
72平铺
然后这个后面是松拧
标准是一个M码
等会我把这个贴上
量的标准一些
没有扣子了
平铺多少的
这样还70
70这个大了是吧
来这个29块
扣2扣2
29扣个2
这个大
标了3M
29扣个2
漂亮给你了
漂亮
29少扣子
少量
OK
谢谢
夏天有点热了吧
不热
这个薄的
薄到很
这个很薄
你接我头
我给你看看
这个很薄很薄
特薄
就夏天穿的
就夏天穿
看呗
薄到很
特别柔软
特柔软
很薄的
这个
你收到货就知道了
超级最软的牛仔了
这个
最柔软的
最薄的牛仔了
这个属于
这个不热了
收到货就知道了
很好
OK
下来
19块
谢谢
好的
来这一款
这个标的是一个L尺码
距指是99
居然是1的
来这一款
这个是个黑色
黑色一款马甲
带领子的这一款
来胸围
胸围是112120
长度75
长度是75
这个咱们有12扣
29扣5
29块扣5扣5
29扣个5扣个5
这个是个马甲
带领了一款马甲
这个好久没看到了
这个和我一样的
和我自留的那条裤子
一样的
就是我的厚一些
这个薄一些
这个贴了个标
有一点点抽丝了感觉
好像有一丁点小抽丝这种
看没
有一点点点点
来这一个
全松拧全松拧
垂直感很好
是这种摆着的
看没
摆着的这一款
这个起码也大
哇这个3L的呢
这个是3L的
腿尾80
80能拉伸110了
腿尾不见
当长
当长41
扣长98
来这个咱们有腰的
29扣8
有一点点微微响
不太是看不出来
29块
扣8扣8
这个垂直感很好
而且这个裤腿可以随意裁剪的
我那个当时我
买的时候我那个裤腿常常脱到地上
不给它剪了
两次
来这个29块
扣8扣8
29扣个8
我那个厚春秋天穿这个夏天穿的
来这一款
这个标的一个L是吗
锯纸的
这个是一个
均
灰绿色的
灰绿色的我这一款是
这个颜色
来这个全松拧花宝腰的
腰围的话是70能拉伸100
70 100
肯为120 128
刚长40
酷长160